- Oh my god.
- Candice are you crying?
- What?
- Are you drunk?
No.
This is my cat.
Look at how cute she is.
- How much have you had?
- What?
This is water.
- Whoa.
- You all right there?
- Yeah, don't worry I'm fine.
- Is she drunk?
- This is a place of business.
- Come here let me smell it.
- Oh my --
Daysha.
- So I have a date
tonight with this one guy,
but then this other guy texted me today
and wants to go out tonight too.
So, like one's really hot--
- I'm actually just here for an interview.
Do you guys usually drink
on Wednesday morning?
- Do you ever think Jordan's kinda hot?
- I feel like you must
have your drunk goggles on.
Well he's nice and all but...
- What?
No, look at the way he's
treating that peppermint patty.
It's like, he's doing a
good job at it, you know?
- Did you just find those
and now you're eating them?
- Yeah.
- They're not your chips though.
- Cool Candice you're
dancing like a drunk girl.
Yeah, we're dancing like drunk girls.
- Frankie you're dancing
like a drunk girl.
- Have you been drinking Candice?
- No, why does everyone say?
I'm doing what hungry people do.
I'm eating.